لكن الاثار ليست سوى واحده من مجموعه
اشياء تتهم اوروبا توتتهم اوروبا بسرقتها
من افريقيا رغم ان دول افريقيا تعد من ضمن
الاغنى عالميا بالموارد الطبيعيه كالنفط
والمعادن تبقى القاره الاكثر فقرا من حيث
التطور والتنميه وكثيره ما توجه اصابع
اللون الى حكومه افريقيه فاسده جزءا
حقيقيا من القصه لكن الجزء الاكبر هو ان
المعاناه هي نتيجه مباشره لقرنين من
العبوديه اعاقبها قرن اخر من الاستبداد
الاستعماري نعود بالزمن خلينا نفهم اكثر
بين عمليه 1501
1867 ما يقرب من 12 مليون ونصف في المليون
شعب افريقي تم شحنهم مقيدين بالثلاثه
العبره المحيط الاطلسي الى الامريكيتين
شباب ونساء تتراوح اعمارهم بين ال 15 وال
و30 ما النتيجه
تضاعف عدد سكان اوروبا بنحو اربعه اضعاف
بين القرنين السابع عشر وال19 قدرت
الزياده السكانيه في افريقيا بنحو 20
مليون نسمه فقط القوه العامله كانت الاساس
وقتها بعض الدول اعتذرت عن هذه الجرائم
مثل المانيا وبلجيكا وهولندا لكن هناك من
رفض الاعتذار واكتفى بالاعتراف فرنسا من
هذه الدول بل انها تدخلت عسكريا في شمال
مالي عام 2000 و 2013 بهدف مواجهه الارهاب
وهذا هو المعلن في العام الثالث توسعت
العمليه وشمل الدول الساحل الافريقيه لكن
السبب الحقيقي قد يكون مختلف ولا نعلم ما
لديها الكثير من الثروات مثلا تحتمل
المرتبه الثالثه افريقيا في انتاج الذهب